Now here's a very important and subtle
point about the completion of a wait.
When wait returns, the only thing that
you know is that buf is safe to reuse.
If the handle is for
a receive, then it must mean
that the message was delivered.
But what about send?
For a send, buffer being available for
use doesn't really tell you anything.
For instance it could mean the message
was delivered since the wave
might actually wait until
the message is delivered, but
it doesn't have to mean that.
In fact it might not even be the case
that the message is even in flight yet.
The precise action is
implementation dependent.
Implementation dependent.
But why?
The answer has to do with buffering
implied by these primitives.
Remember that the processes
are executing asynchronously.
Also remember that a send completes when
the caller may reuse the message buffer.
So let's imagine what might happen.
Here are two ranks, i and j.
Rank i is computing, and
then decides to send a message to j.
In the meantime, j is running
off asynchronously for a long,
long time before it decides, oh,
I'm ready to receive a message from i.
So the send could arrive way before
the receive is actually ready.
So should the send stop and
wait until the receive has been
posted before it starts delivering?
In this scenario, rank i would
have to wait a long, long time.
What rank i might do
instead is make a copy and
then later on decide
to start the delivery.
That way rank i can kind of keep going.
So by leaving the meaning of the
completion of a send a little bit loose,
you give more freedom to the
implementation to make a good trade off.
Okay, so
what's the punchline of all this?
Well, it means that when you're
trying to determine if your algorithm
is correct,
meaning that a sent message is received,
you need to prove that for every posted
send, there is a matching receive.
This protocol that sends, match,
receives is called two-sided messaging.
Two-sided suggests there
might be a one sided, and
in fact that's kind of what
shared memory communication is.
I'll let you think about that.